thanks everyone for allowing me to speak
here at Pi data Global and I'm
geroniella and
as the title says this will be about the
maps
and
let me just very quickly rush through my
background it's already been mentioned I
live in
Norway and I work for a real python
which is a website for
essentially python education so you can
come there and read articles about all
about python I've been working with
python now for about a decade and
earlier
um I guess my main background comes from
working with the Norwegian mapping
Authority in terms of maps and I've also
been doing some Consulting work with
maps
so let's dive into it so essentially
what I'm planning to do here is do some
demos of a few different packages
and and kind of just give you a teaser
of what you can do with these kind of
things
so the first one that we'll have a look
at is one called folium
and fully and let's just run this code
so we can have a look at it and it wraps
around a JavaScript library called
leaflet which which kind of runs
a lot of Open Source
versions of maps so essentially here you
have an interactive map we can move
around on the map we can zoom in on the
map we can zoom out from the map and
things like this so it's kind of what
you're used to
in terms of a web map and getting this
to to run through python is essentially
as easy as just creating this map
object right there and here I just say
where do I want to start kind of
centering my map so I could say that I
want to start closer to Oslo and here I
kind of say it which zoom level I want
to start so if I kind of come out like
this there's a Sim level close to zero
at least and as they kind of go in it's
more and more zoomed in so friends if I
do something like this then I'm here now
in southern Norway for instance so you
can kind of set up things like this
so this gives you immediate access to to
a map and let me actually one little
thing before I move on so this I'm
running just in a jupyter notebook so
here you can kind of see the map
directly but you can also just save this
by doing
something like this you can save this as
an HTML file that you can then serve
um however you serve static HTML files
okay so
um what else can we do with volume so so
we can add in more information on top of
the map so it's just not showing a map
so for now I'm just going to Define four
locations that I'll kind of be using a
little bit throughout the presentation
so essentially here I have a name on The
Nest right there and then I have the
latitude and longitude
um and similar here for Oslo Barcelona
and Saint Louis
so let's just Define those and then
let's see what we can start doing here
so here I'm just creating a new map
centering at some location like this
adding assume and here I'm also just
choosing a different tile set so the
tiles that defines the look and feel of
your map so if we just run it like this
you can see that this is stem and
watercolor tiles it which is made by
Stone it's it's a really fun uh
tile set that just looks like it's a
watercolor painting but it has all the
details so you can see here if I
actually zoom into
towards Oslo you can see that we get
more and more detail and for instance up
here we're up in the
in the mountains that there's a ski
Arena so this weird little shape there
is is a ski jump for instance so it has
a lot of detail and this is based on top
of a
open street maps which is sort of like a
Wikipedia for maps
okay uh what could we do now with these
locations so here I just add a loop
where I just Loop over my locations
dictionary and then for each of them I
add a Folia marker so you can see here I
have a marker I give it the latitude and
longitude I specify a name as a pop-up
and then I just add it to the map
so if we run this we get the same map
but now you can see that we have these
small markers so there's Lewis Barcelona
Oslo
and again we can kind of still zooming
in on this and kind of see more
more and more information
in addition to these kind of markers you
can also have circles or
or nice logos on things you could have
ADD lines lots of information you can
kind of add on top of this if you want
so in general folium it's a great
package just for exploring and getting
an overview of the data and also you can
use it to to visualize the data to end
users since it's a very intuitive
a way of presenting your data
that there is a great tutorial it's like
a quick start that kind of shows more of
this at their web page uh one thing I
did show here that it also supports this
corplet
plots where you can kind of add a lot of
color to areas and so on we'll see some
example of this later
so let me move on to geopandis uh so
geopanders is this kind of magical
package that just brings together a lot
of functionality for from many different
ideal spatial python packages and it's
really powerful for doing any kind of
geospatial analysis
so some of the packages it built on top
of are pandas which you may be aware of
it's kind of one of the big data
analysis packages shapely we'll have a
look at in a minute it's just a
sort of like a package for describing
Point polygon slides and those kind of
things in a more abstract setting
Fiona is a library that can just read
and write tons of different geofile
formats as your spatial information
often comes in weird formats so some of
them are things like shapefiles Studio
Json other stuff
and then there's a package called pipe
approach which is based on the project
project and this is for projecting
coordinates essentially or transforming
coordinates and um
we will not go deep into this at all but
I'll kind of just point out so far we
worked with
latitude and longitude but often if you
need to do precise
geospatial analysis you want to
transform to other coordinates which
which may work better especially locally
so so this is something that
is done by pie perch and we will not go
deep into detail of this package but
we'll see an example where it's used
then there's also a package called
discard which is kind of something that
interacts with matlablib for creating
this kind of more publication type plots
and figures and maps in this case so
it's it's nice for drawing stuff onto
this
and the open this as recently also
gained support for interacting with
folium so we'll see an example of that
quite shortly
so before
demoing geopenders itself I'm just going
to show you a little bit about what
shapely does so here we have
importing shape layer let me put the
geometry geometry and part of shapely
and here you can see I Define a point
and here the numbers are coordinates but
they don't have any satio graphical
meaning in this case so the shapely
doesn't care whether this represents
latitude longitude or some other
coordinate system
so if we just run this and I have here
defined point the line and a square this
Square I Define as a polygon
then we can have a look at them so for
instance I could just look at the
coordinates that we just defined so here
we see that the point coordinates are
two and three I could also go in here
and look at for instance the line
coordinates and see that I get this 5 0
2 6 and so on
if I just inspect the line or the square
here in the notebook it also has support
for just drawing itself so you can kind
of get to know where we will have
um things look as you can see this is
kind of abstracted away that you don't
really see
if I change the line coordinates the
line would still more or less look like
this
um
what's maybe even more interesting is
that the shapely comes with support for
lots of different calculations
Transformations and predicate checks and
things like this so for instance I could
put a point together with the line so
now there you see my point and there I
see my line and now things are kind of
looking a little bit I guess they're
still abstracted out but they're still a
little bit more concrete or I could just
look at um the actual string
representation of this and where you can
see that this is now a collection of a
line string which is shapeless name for
lines and a point
and I can calculate stuff so for
instance in terms of these coordinates I
can find that the distance from the
point to the closest point on the line
is 1.34
or we could take our Square calculate
the area or we could do checks between
different things so this the square
contained the point is the point inside
of the square yes it is does the line
intersect the square so the stat across
the square yes it does and so on so it
kind of comes with lots of different
checks like this
okay back to geopen this uh so what
geopanda supports or gives you is a
geodata frame
um so this is more or less a pandas data
frame so it kind of has the same
setup so you have your data ordered into
columns and rows where typically you'll
have one variable in say the statistical
kind of sensor feature as one column and
then you'll have an observation as a row
in your data frame so what I'm doing
here is that I'm just creating a small
geodata frame from scratch
and this looks a lot like how you'd
create a pandas data frame
especially if we disregard these two
lines then what I'm doing here is that
I'm just creating a column name and a
column size
so let's run this and have a look at it
so the name I'm just taking from these
locations that we defined earlier the
size is definitely just
um
a very artificial feature but I just
take the length of the name and store it
here in a separate column just to to
have something to play with which it's
very simple data
now the Magic in a sense of the data
frame comes from this geometry column so
you can see here that it looks more or
less like a regular column
um but the naming of this is is kind of
special and it plays a special role with
the geodata frame and what I've put into
this column is now these are shapely
points and I just took the latitude and
longitude and
and threw it into it and one tiny note
is that I can reverse the order so
geopentus wants longitude latitude
I also defined here something called the
CRS a coordinate reference system and
this is where I kind of take my abstract
number since give the meaning so
this is sort of like a big database of
different reference systems and four
three two six that is your typical
latitude longitude reference system
so this is now a data frame but it has
some geometrical superpowers as we'll
see quite surely
so the first thing is that we can
uh look at these things in volume so the
method explore like this lets us explore
our data so you can see now that it just
pops up a volume thing and if you stare
really hard at this you might see that
there's a small blue dot that Oslo over
there there's another one down here in
Barcelona
and so the default of points is not that
readable but we can add in
lots of different parameters to kind of
change how the map looks so in this case
I'll just add a slightly bigger point so
we could probably even make them
be getting this and now we can kind of
see that at least here I have my points
and if I would have a data frame with
even more fancy geometry then that would
also be plotted on top of here so you
could have lines polygons and all those
kind of things
okay uh
geodata frames are pandas data frames so
if you've been using pandas a little bit
you know that you can do lots of
interesting analysis on this so here's a
very basic filter
so I'm just doing a query on this so
give me all the observations or rows
here where the size is less than eight
so that remember the size in this case
was just the number of letters in the in
the name so that gives me these two
points for instance
uh instead of creating your geopandex
data frames from scratch you typically
want to read in data files so here I
have
already downloaded some open data that
are essentially just information about
all the countries
so it looks more or less like this you
can see let's see there we have some
some names here if I scroll all the way
to the right we'll see that we have this
geometry column
and that is the all-important one for
our Dia data frames
and that there's even much more
information here so if I look at all the
columns I don't remember I guess we saw
it recently that there's 50
columns or something like this
and let's here just point out that there
is a population estimate uh column let's
see if I'm not able to edit there and
also there's a continent which we'll use
later and so on so so that there's lots
of information we can pick out of this
first let's just do so earlier we did
the Explorer I can also do just a Dot
Plot and this just plots our data now as
a Matlab kind of plot so if you look at
this a little bit carefully you should
be able to see that there are some
borders between each of the countries
here but we'll see that much clearer
soon because here I'll just do another
filtering and here I filter out and
let's just look at the countries that
have more than 50 million
uh population and here you can see that
we still recognize some of the countries
there's Brazil for instance
South Africa and so on and what they've
done here then is
I guess we can just quickly
look at this I get this filtered data
frame and then I just say that I want to
plot a filtered data frame
um
now to make this even more interesting
we could also add some color so this is
kind of what I mentioned earlier as a
corporate
plot so in this case I'm plotting the
I'm almost plotting the population
eventually I'm using a color map here
and then I'm plotting what I call here
the log population and mainly just so
that we don't get uh just just kind of
distracted by some of the countries
having extremely
High populations and some small so now
we kind of are able to see a little bit
of the difference between the the
smaller populations as well
so to kind of sum this up
um we can think of geopand as as kind of
the Workhorse that can do all kinds of
analysis of geodata and it kind of
brings together all of these different
packages and
and it's extremely powerful than to do
all kinds of data analysis conversion
Transformations and visualizations
a small little package that I also kind
of want to highlight a little bit this
one called complexity and
this this kind of combines a little bit
to the power of what we saw in folian
and and the images that we saw
sort of like more of the Matlab kind of
plots
uh because what we have with
the matplotlib kind of plots is that we
get these kind of these kind of plots so
here you can see I take this country
list and I just look at everything that
in North America
and again I use the population to kind
of
give me some kind of corporate thing now
by themselves these may or may not be uh
interesting in this case the country
shapes is something that we often are
able to recognize anyway but we can add
some context
um
to our maps by using okay let's see by
using contextually and what it does is
that it just runs off and downloads this
kind of web map tiles so the ones that
you saw in when we are using volume and
adds those as background so now we can
see that okay we have the North America
here we see a little bit of Africa over
there we see a little bit of South
America over there and so on
so this can be extremely useful
especially if you're doing more kind of
detailed things
uh
so how this contextually work is that
you just create your regular plots and
then you just say I want to add a base
map to to this axis so that's kind of
the plot and then here you can choose
what kind of zoom level you want on your
on your background map
I'll just note that since this kind of
runs off and downloads these web map
tiles if you do a high zoom level here
things could take a long time
here's a different
um
uh kind of plot so so here I'm plotting
uh let's see these are
countries in this in South America where
it starts with B so this would be Brazil
and Bolivia
and again I color them by population and
now if we add in the base map for this
now you see it takes a little bit of
time uh but there we go and what I've
done here is that instead of using just
the default map I'm using
uh some tiles from S3 that gives us the
satellite image instead so you can
choose different kind of providers for
your backgrounds
we can also work with geojson so in this
particular file right here I just have
actually one polygon something called
Holman comb which is this Arena up in
in the Hills above or slow that we
zoomed into earlier in the in the chat
in the talk and here I also use
something called which is a
service in Norway for just getting
access to really high
detailed images so these are
aerial images and here you can see I can
combine these so essentially the same
principle that we saw in the South
America earlier but now we're kind of
doing it much more locally so there you
can see the ski jump right there here's
the arena with the stands and so on
so with contextually you can kind of
extend the areas where you can use the
web map tile services and things like
this and it also supports some simple
Transformations and it's great for
building this kind of publication
uh visualization Maps
and yeah the last package I want to look
at is uh Works a little bit differently
from what
I guess the ones we've seen earlier so
geopenders works with what's called
Vector data so you have
everything is defined in terms of
vectors or coordinates
um and and you can have a lot of freedom
in terms of
directions and things like this and lots
of flexibility but often you also have
data that are just data on a grid so
typically your images and things like
this and the example data I'm using here
is a Surface model that kind of then
just gives me access to the exact height
of the surface and this particular one
is again in the area around this Arena
that we saw in the previous plot
if I just use a raster i o here I can
open this file you see it's a tiff for
you I guess a geotiff that comes with a
little bit of extra information and in
this case
and we can again see the CRS and the
coordinate reference system and it has
some kind of number over there this is
the UTM 32 coordinate system if you know
about those things
um and it comes here with this transform
that kind of says how did the grid
points kind of translate to to this
coordinate reference system
so what is this file really
I let's try to plot it so I can
and plot it like this
and what you see here on the left is now
the colored version of the data inside
of the file so so this think of this
more or less as a say a numpy matrix
that where you have your array you have
your rows and columns and for each point
you have the height above sea level
uh so in this case it kind of comes from
the blue here is close to sea level
green is kind of going uphill and then
the the brown stuff here is kind of the
top and if you notice the green uh dimp
that we have over there and that is the
ski jump Arena
so with raster IO you can do the
different kind of analysis on it so for
instance I can ask for getting the
Contours which are just lines of the
same height essentially so this will
look like your height lines on a regular
map and maybe the ones that you'll
really again point out there are the uh
this the ski jump Arena you can kind of
see here in the top there
uh we could also now combine this with
what we saw earlier this uh let's see
there we have Holman call which was this
geojson file and I'm here saying that I
want to just mask out my Surface model
with this geojson and crop it off
and then I'm going to show what I'm left
with here so if I do this
um you can see now that I'm kind of just
getting a smaller part of the height
model that I saw earlier but the the the
the limits the boundaries of what you
see here in the mask at least the lower
boundaries are coming from the geojson
and then it's kind of cut off on the top
here because I didn't provide a surface
model that actually covered the whole
Arena but again you can kind of see the
sky jump in the in the runway down there
foreign
what you get here is then a lot of power
when you work with the raster data so
raster data can I post to Vector data
and raster data are the ones that are
kind of greeted data
as we also saw we can kind of combine
our Vector data like the geojson thing
we had to to mask our raster data and
things like this
so with rasterio you can again do lots
of this different Transformations you
can change coordinate reference systems
if you want to you can combine different
uh different raster data into one bigger
one so I didn't show it here but if I
had downloaded kind of the surface model
right next to the one that we were
looking at I could have kind of covered
the whole Arena
so that takes me to the end of the
presentation so thanks everyone for your
attention I will put the talk on on
GitHub and if you want to reach out I'm
available as g a yellow in most places
thanks gear uh we have a
I mean uh really it was a great talk uh
I got a really as far as the basics are
concerned it's it's really a great talk
so we have we have some questions out
there I'd like to yeah pitch them to you
so Carlos has
question that can I change the base map
when jio pandas dot explore when using
geopandors.explore
uh
so yeah the quick answer is yes and
let's see if we come back to G appendix
here and so so I just showed uh
let's see the appendix Explorer here
um so I think I should be able to do
this yeah and so Japan this Explorer
comes with lots of different parameters
so you can kind of change out more or
less everything it does here and it's
kind of passing those kind of parameters
down to down to the underlying package
so this marker keywords that I added
here
passes things down to to volume for the
markers but yeah I think here yeah we
can see here we can change tiles here
for instance to to change to different
tile set
so I could do here stuff like let's see
summon water color
and and we get the different base map
for it
it's really great
we can have another question and that's
why Joe Tom else
I have had trouble with jio pandas
special was slow what kind of techniques
tips parameters should I look into when
that happens
uh yes so let's see if I so I guess I
didn't really uh demo this uh properly
but um in in geopenders you can do all
of this underlying shapely operations so
I could ask for instance which country
is in
inside of a bounding boxes things like
this
uh
it can definitely be slow and there's an
ongoing effort to to make it faster so
so if you have the luxury of it one way
to make it faster is just sit and wait
for a few months
um but um
otherwise uh what's uh what's really
important is uh kind of the detail of
your geometries so so if you're kind of
doing
uh things like intersections or things
like this and you have very complicated
geometries so if you have a very
detailed geometry that kind of goes
let's see I don't remember if we had a
good example down here
uh so so this one is not very detailed
for instance in Norway you can see we
don't have any of the islands but if you
kind of have one very detailed one with
all those things and they're not really
important to your analysis
it can help a lot with speed by just
simplifying your your polygons and some
of the ways of doing this is maybe you
can get away with just using something
called the convex hole which is kind of
just a polygon that's drawn around
your actual polygon because the simple
polygons you have the the faster these
collaborations will be
yeah I quite sort of agree with you yeah
on convex cell is a quite a good option
to
you know speed up over here plus I'd
like to chip in one another package
called as geofeather so jio feather also
is quite good at handling shape files if
you are talking or just reading the
geometries and writing these geometries
so in case of complex geometries
geofeather has a sort of around 1.522
times the speed up as compared to
geopanders so yeah nice thanks yeah and
uh yeah we have another question that is
by rishika
do you have any advice for how to deal
with clustering points on the map when
we zoom out real-time clustering is very
slow for us we don't use Python though
yep
right so
let's see if I just
um
so so the the the the the the
uh yeah so the question kind of deals
with when you have lots of points so I
don't really have a good demo of it here
um when when they kind of start to
overlap you can kind of cluster them
together as one thing like this and I
have not really dealt with uh that
personally so I don't know if I have any
good uh advice I've been kind of using
whatever's in in some of the packages
where I so uh yeah I don't really know
good ways of speeding it up I guess
unfortunately